our next guest is an actor and brilliant
director having made such classics as I
know he's so sick of hearing this the
princess the princess bride When Harry
Met Sally my favorite of all time this
is spinal temple it goes on and on and
on
rider honor is also so extremely
outspoken on politics tonight he joins
me on set for a little conversation
little back and forth a Rob how are you
nice to see you nice to be here we did
week we were we ran into each other
restaurant last night and there you and
now we're talking there it's good it's
purple territory we have some we should
have we should have negotiated this
thing maybe we wouldn't have a the first
things are talking but they gonna shut
the government down like wow I'm here in
LA I want to talk about Hollywood
stuffing let's talk about politics here
um you you started this committee with
David Fromm as an old friend of mine
about investigating the whole Russia
connection and you know I first read
about it I mean yes be honest I mean I
kind of laughs I'm like what the heck is
a Hollywood guy and then the guy who
writes for The Atlantic they're gonna do
like 20 lawyers and Washington with an
unlimited budget can't do explain that
well first of all we have a you know a
really good Advisory Board James clapper
and Michael Hayden Mike Morrell commands
Ron Paul you know and John Brennan is
there has now been involved so we've got
some you know pretty knowledgeable
people in the intelligence community and
the reason I started it is because you
know I just felt that the public was not
really understanding the gravity of what
has happened and and the warfare has
changed you know that we have this cyber
war now which you can't feel you know if
we had been attacked let's say the
buildings get knocked down or a bomb
blows up in New York City everybody says
oh we got a we got a do some I just
Russia and why not China - I mean 50
million of my personnel files including
mine yeah no you'd listen there's a lot
of cyber because that was the most
recent and very effective very effective
and what they were able to pull off and
it's nothing new I mean they pull off
change the outcome of the election I'm
not I'm not suggesting they did or not I
I can't I don't know about that what I
do know is that they were able to have
thousands of trolls and BOTS and go
through Facebook and take out ads and
every campaign Republican Democrat you
put out your propaganda you always do if
paid ads on television weren't good you
wouldn't see people because I mean Trump
colluded with Russia that Russia is
really good I didn't say they did I'm
not I'm not talking about that because
whether or not he you know there was
coordination between Trump and Russians
that's for Muller and the congressional
investigations to determine right that's
not this what this is about this is
about being attacked in a new way of
warfare and whether or not we're gonna
be up to the task I think we fell asleep
after the the Soviets collapsed and they
are you worried about the Soviets back
then I mean I was old college at
Dartmouth well I don't remember
Hollywood rallying to Ronald Reagan I
remember the opposite actually but
before the way older than you and we we
had to hide under desks but you weren't
supporting Reagan right you couldn't
stand Reagan back no no I was in the
support of Reagan he took down the
Russians you're taking on the Russians
so you're not a model now you're taking
on the Russians like Reagan took on the
Russians when it was actually mutually
assured destruction now we're beyond
mutually assured destruction still not
great but Russia's economy is smaller
than France yes it is but here's what is
smart about Putin is we basically beat
them at during the Cold War we wait but
we they they they spent themselves into
oblivion trying to Reagan yeah well
because of a lot of a lot of a lot of a
lot of different presidents did helped
it to do that but Putin figured out for
a half a billion dollars a very
inexpensive thing I can weaponize cyber
war and
we people have to understand the
capacity that cyber would not just
invading a collection
yeah there's blowing up during Obama I
want to get to the fun stuff in a moment
the fun he's talking about the other
stuff is fun and he talked about pause
and that funny we're like on each
other's topic yeah but you know Putin
did pretty well in the Obama years I
mean went into Crimea obviously the
Ukraine we you know he obviously grew
his popularity at home so the idea that
like Trump would be some you know
Nirvana for Putin I never really did get
that because he did really well in the
Obama Clinton era they didn't do the
reset the reset failed so there's so
much bad but Obama did you know whether
or not you think they were effective did
have sanctions after they invaded Crimea
there's been a lot of talk of removing
those sanctions we had sanctions passed
by 98 to 2 in the in the Senate and
virtually everybody in Russia Russia
it's like the Brady Bunch Marcia Marcia
Marcia Russia Russia Russia I mean at
some point that becomes comical right it
becomes funnier than the stuff you
produced which is my favorite you know
just a favorite word that says you don't
care right this I do care about it but I
think that you going down the wrong
you're going down the wrong rabbit hole
it's a rabbit hole but let's talk about
what politics does to art okay okay
politics and art they've always had a
connection obviously there's always been
a connection and the conservatives in
Hollywood you know the ones that will
actually rear their heads say that
there's a blacklist in Hollywood that if
you express support for Trump basically
it's like what Harvey Weinstein do
people who in some you don't work I
don't I don't know that there's a
blacklist but I can tell you that the
vast majority of artists directors
writers actors are liberal there's no
question about that and there's a reason
for that because you a liberal to have a
very big view of things you know I
thought this is what I've said I said
this to to Bill Clinton in the Oval
Office I said you know the difference
between Republicans and Democrats
Republicans know they're right
Democrats entertain the possibility that
they
might be wrong and that's the big
difference and that's why you see
liberals drawn to the arts because it's
more of an open minded kind of thing and
I'm open minded look I came on I love it
this is what it should be about I love
it I think it's fantastic now are you
bothered looking back looking back in
the 70s I was I grew up watching you
know you is Michael stivic the liberal
do-gooder on on the family right did it
bug you that Archie Bunker was more
beloved than your character because you
are kind of your character he was a
liberal who ended up playing this kind
of hot you know this blue-collar got a
brass Obol guy who but love he had a
lovable he did it any luck we got a lot
of criticism because people were stopped
him well I was saying how dare you make
a lovable bigot right and we always said
he's a human being but is it loves his
tree loves his wife he loves us is his
daughter and and that makes him human
and you said but you say Trump you said
he's a racist you said he will you yeah
he absolutely is not like doing it well
do I look like a person who would hang
around with someone who is ready I don't
hang around them but I've known him for
15 years I will tell you this and you
have to believe me I'm gonna you you
might think he's you know I just go by
what you say you might disagree this
policies that's fine I have no problem
with that he's not a racist
the why did he spread the say about
Obama why did he spread this thing about
Obama be he's not a racist if you're a
racist I don't say Winfrey would have
been friends with him Phil why does he
say that there's good on both sides when
there's a Nazis mark sometimes he's not
the most precise in his Lincoln why does
he say [ __ ] countries why don't like
Obama said s house or s place is s storm
about Libya or Lindsey Graham is he a
racist who talked about the hellhole of
Mexico and Central America I mean again
I'm just putting all of these things
together Central Park five not rent back
to black people there's a thing so so
you so you anyway so getting back to
race okay but you don't know I'm like I
don't say people arranged I don't lie
about well I've met him one
he thought he was a narcissist like
nobody in this town is narcissistic when
you see I read your comment about Trump
he's a big one of the biggest narcissus
I'm like you hang out with the people
who read other people's lines for a
living you bet okay I can look at
themselves in the mirror all day look
I'm in television too but come on I mean
narcissus okay so let me tell you I work
with the biggest narcissists in the
world yeah actors are the biggest
narcissists in the world they want
attention they want to be loved they
don't even come close to this guy in the
one time I spend with him I was with him
with Billy Crystal and we it was just
another person I adore it was at his
hotel for one of his fights you know
they had a fight but I think nurses and
he basically already talked about
himself I know that's a show I mean I
mean Bill Clinton was a smooth operator
but he might be better at hiding his
narcissistic tendencies Clinton Obama
I mean Reagan actually was not
narcissistic at all and I used to work
for him not narcissistic but most of the
premium JFK well usually usually you get
to that position and I need that you
need to be low but you got much do you
have like so Archie like you can't like
people compared Trump the Archie Bunker
okay fine whatever but from Queens but
you don't see anything redeeming at all
in Donald Trump not I don't see him I
don't see him be lovable too let's say
for instance he's walking up the the
stairs to get into the Air Force One
yeah and it's raining and he has the
umbrella closely my goodness I mean
that's I mean that's what you do is you
observe you know and his kid and and
Melania are getting rained on and he
doesn't do a you know it's just a thing
about looking out for other people
caring about other people so the good
economy doesn't I mean I
yeah that's not about caring I'm talking
about a human being caring and loving
and being a loving person government's
not government as I'm not saying the
government should love I'm talking about
him as a human being too low back to my
question you're judging his family I
just I I literally dodging his family
I'm judging his baby okay so I know
Clinton looking at this gave
it got oral sex in the Oval Office when
his wife was sleeping when when his wife
was sleeping in the you know in the
residence we had LBJ who you just did
this movie about and you said really
nice things about LBJ and he's
fascinating character obviously I think
it had it not been for the Vietnam War
he would have gone down as one of the
greatest presidents of all time second
to Roosevelt LBJ passed more legislation
than anybody or LA Times interview which
is true true but also he had another
side to him yes he did urinating in a
sink inviting people into his bathroom
showing off his abdominal scar I showed
the bathrooms yeah exposing his private
parts after a while nothing surprises a
biographer like Robert Dalek of Lyndon
Baines Johnson he bragged about his
womanizing he said he was more of a
womanizer than JFK my point being
judging political context he had a lot
of flaws a personal flaw I'm not I'm not
judging you know Donald Trump I don't
like his policies I mean you don't like
a spouse no no no no no no no that's not
true I don't like his policies that is
true but I don't like the way he
conducts his life
the way he treats you just did a movie
about LBJ who how don't worry about
personal flaws I don't like a man who
goes like this with with with towels
with paper towels I don't I don't like
that I don't like the way he treats
other people okay so the paper towel
throw he's you know was he actually no
no Houston the hurricane D you're making
some really bad arguments Nora Thanks
they're smart as hell you know better
than to say when I make that comment I'm
talking about the way his behavior the
way in which he behaves towards other
people that's all that's all I'm talking
about I'm not talking about anything
else
okay just before we let you go your dad
is such an amazing man and talent oh you
gotta say you're great because you try
to find the the differences and the and
the tension even when there shouldn't be
I think that's pretty odd I mean I think
I mean it's it's a conversation and I'm
just and again Rob Reiner is someone who
actually should be lauded because he's
someone who doesn't agree with probably
a lot of what I think that's fine
but he actually comes in
for conversation and a lot and I'll tell
you Republicans and Democrats on Capitol
Hill Rob they a lot of them won't come
on the show because I actually read
legislation who hi those who come
Lindsey Graham Jeff Flake John McCain
welcome he's not feeling well but you
know Cory Gardner a lot of Republicans
they're afraid to answer questions about
their job and I find that to be
disturbing the fact that you're willing
and you've gone on with Tucker I know
you went on with O'Reilly and that is
really not a conversation
it's really good and more people should
do that and we do have a lot in common
believe it or not because I love your
craft and what you've done in Hawley we
don't know garyun politics politics is
about that much of life but your dad is
someone I also really really admire he's
95 years yeah yeah he's got 96 and 2
months as long as my mother would have
been he gets up every morning and he
says if I'm not in the obits I eat
breakfast I do bits to make sure I'm not
in him yeah and what what life lesson
did you learn from him that you carry
with you would you get up anymore
the biggest thing I got from him is the
way in which he conducted his career the
way in which he treated other people and
the way in which he did his work I I you
know it wasn't like he sat me down and
taught me I just watched the way he
behaved and how he handled his career
and and it was like a regular guy you
know so that's what I got from him more
than anything
hey thanks for being here hey will you
come back on yes absolutely talk about
when maybe the government will be
running maybe there won't be any show
here because there'll be no government
I'm turning the lights off right now
riders turning the lights off